Now, the first two terms that we need to understand are,
firstly, distance. Now, distance, like it says here,
is the length of the actual path traveled between the initial
and final positions. So if I am over here
and I walk to some other place, take the roads and walk to some
other place, then distance is how much I walked.
Even if you look at GPS or even if you look at navigation
in your phones, that path that they trace out, that length of the path
that they show you, these many kilometers you need to travel, that is the distance.
That path may be curved. That path may be circular.
It can have any shape, but it just tells you from this
point to this point how much path you actually need to cover.
The other part to this is called the displacement.
And displacement is said to be the shortest straight line distance
directed from the initial position to the final position,
irrespective of the path. In order to better understand
this, look at this diagram over here. So suppose this is my
point A. This is point A, and I need
to go from this point A all the way to this point
B. Now, because there are obstacles in between,
let's assume that there are roads and everything. So I cannot go
straight from this point to the other. So I go a bit in this direction,
then I go up, so on, so forth, and I
come back to this point. This entire yellow
line, this is the distance, because this is actually the path that I have
taken. However, the displacement is
the shortest distance between those two points. And whenever you
want the shortest distance between these two points, they will
generally be the straight line connecting them. So this
yellow line is the distance. The red line is the
displacement. It's the shortest distance possible. So you immediately
get an idea over here that the distance cannot
be less than the displacement. The displacement is the least value
that the distance can have. Because if I want to go from point A
to point B, suppose there are no obstacles in between,
the actual path that I can travel would be just this line.
In that case, my distance becomes equal to my displacement.
So displacement is the minimum value.
Distance will either be that value or it will be greater than that if
I take any other path. All right, so displacement
also another important thing. Displacement is a vector quantity.
Why? Because displacement, since it's in a straight line,
it also has a defined direction. And because
of that direction, displacement becomes a vector quantity. But distance,
distance is a scalar quantity. That is why if you look at
this path, this entire path has no fixed direction for
this region. Up till this region, I'm moving in that side.
Then I move up, then I move again to that side, I move down,
and so on. So my direction is constantly changing.
So for distance, you do not have a defined direction, hence it's a scalar.
But for displacement, because it's a straight line and that direction
is maintained throughout, you consider displacement to be a vector.
All right? So I hope the concepts of distance and displacement are clear, because these
will be used quite often.
Now, another example to properly illustrate distance
and displacement. So over here, I have a particle
that moves like it says it moves over the arc PQ on
a circle of radius, capital R. So over here,
this is the path actually taken. So if this is the
path through which the particle moves, the points that it needs to go is from
point P all the way to point Q. So this
is the actual path taken, which means the distance is
the arc length PQ. You can even figure out if
theta is given and the radius is given R. You know, this PQ
is just equal to R theta. You can even figure that out.
That is the distance traveled. And because you're going from
point P to point Q, you can even figure out what the
displacement is going to be. The displacement is
going to be this line over here. Now, that is not the path you
have taken, but that is the shortest distance between the two because
it's a straight line connecting those two points. So displacement
is a straight line PQ. See? It's still PQ.
In both of these cases, it's PQ because it's the same points you're going
to you're going from one point to the other is the same points.
However, the path taken ensures the distance becomes the arc,
and displacement becomes the straight line.
All right.